It seems like there's so much going on right now.
Donald Trump, Joe Biden, now Mike Pence --
all have classified documents in their homes.
The NFL playoffs are in full swing.
The NFL this weekend.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Egg prices are soaring.
And Dunkin' is making plans
to offer their own alcoholic beverages.
[ Audience cheers ] There's a lot to go over.
Let's just jump in, cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash." Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up, the classified documents scandal.
They just keep finding more. First it was Trump, then Biden.
Now Mike Pence. At this point, Americans are tired of it.
They just want to turn off the news and watch...
the NFL playoffs.
This weekend.
It's Bengals versus Chiefs, 49ers versus Eagles...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...for a trip to the Super Bowl.
The stakes are high. Almost as high as...
egg prices.
They are soaring,
and Congress might even investigate what's going on.
At these prices, instead of eating eggs for breakfast,
you're better off... drinking booze at Dunkin'.
That's right. Dunkin' is planning
to sell its own alcoholic drinks.
People were like, "Ew, what's even in it?"
And Dunkin' said... "That's classified."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
The papers -- The papers are everywhere.
This week, President Biden was like,
"I apologize for keeping documents in ma-garage,
ma-office, and...
ma-homes."
That is the Kansas City quarterback.
And he's got to play Cincinnati's Joe Burrow.
Both of them are going to play hard.
Neither one is gonna just roll over easy...
scrambled, fried.
No matter how you make them, they're expensive.
So if you've got a bunch of eggs right now, keep them to yourself.
Maybe even...
hide them.
Mike Pence -- Mike Pence has been so stressed,
he's thinking about doing shots over at...
Drunkin' Donuts.
Seriously, booze at Dunkin'?
Even people in Boston are like, "Sorry, but I think I'll...
pass." That's the quarterback's job.
And if they screw up on Sunday, their whole season will be...
totally wasted.
In conclusion, don't miss, kickers...
stop it, misters...
penny pinch-ahs...
wicked piss-ah.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪